brandon elkins aaron rodgers knew he
wouldn't be traded this offseason coming
off an incredible season of being the
mvp i think he's created all this drama
to set the stage to be traded next off
season
knowing that's more realistic thoughts
hey i don't
disagree with that concept and peter
king made the suggestion weeks ago
of a very simple solution packers say to
aaron rodgers come back this year
and play this year and after the season
we'll trade you i think the packers get
more trading him after the season than
they would get trading
now but i think at some level mark
murphy doesn't want him there
and if he shows up there's a chance the
packers soften
in there we're not trading you mindset
because
i think they would just prefer at this
point not to go through the full season
of drama driven by aaron rodgers
philip krajewski will chris sims
remember to show up for work or continue
to wake and bake uh we got three more
weeks until sims has to come back it's
just me for the hiatus edition but i i
fully expect that sims will be back
and ready to go and back into retox full
detox for three more weeks re-talks as
of august 9.
sean alvashad this is an important
question what are your thoughts on james
gandolfini almost replacing steve carell
on the office
i first became aware of that reading the
book that i mentioned a couple of weeks
ago
the oral history of the office and i had
no idea
how close it was between james
gandolfini
and james spader to be the new boss post
michael scott steve carell and the extra
bit of news that came out last week and
i saw this tweeted by jimmy trayno of
si.com nbc offered gandolfini 4 million
to do it hbo paid him 3 million
to not do it so that would explain why i
didn't do it i think it would have been
awesome
i think it would have been spectacular
and
i think those last few seasons of the
show
would have been remembered a lot more
fondly than they are really
from the moment michael scott let me
step back
after pam and jim got married it kind of
started
to creep downhill after they had the
baby it started to accelerate
after michael scott left that's when it
fell off the cliff and
i don't really remember much about the
last two seasons i watched them
i remember not liking it and i remember
feeling compelled to keep watching
because
of the fact that i'd been invested for
so long and and i think it wouldn't have
been that vibe
if it had been james gandolfini instead
of james spader
at the at the end of the series
oh let's see matt and saint pete what
would have to happen for the nfl to take
action against the bucks for the brady
mcl situation for all we know they're
going to
for all we know they're going to do it
secretly you know a couple of years ago
the steelers
and coach mike tomlin got penalized by
the league fined by the league
for not disclosing ben rothsberger's
elbow injury and
that elbow went out during week two
of the 2019 season and there were fines
that were imposed the nfl does not like
to aggressively
enforce that rule because as i said
earlier the league doesn't want
people to realize how widespread the
violations are
of the injury reporting rules and they
are widespread
brandonfield97 uk fan would you
ever consider coming to london and doing
a special pft podcast when the annual
london games are on i mean the problem
is the london games happen during the
regular season and we're here for
football night in america
and the time change and the travel it
just doesn't work we want to come to
london
we were getting ready to come to london
before the pandemic once the pandemic is
finally over whenever that may be
we're coming to london i guarantee you
that james mcdonough
otherwise known as at dr j144 do you see
this season going well for cliff
kingsbury and steve kahn i live here in
arizona and think they're
clearly the fourth fourth best team in
the division i'm not as
optimistic as some are nationally i
remember when
the cardinals used to be in the nfc east
prior to 2002
that was their division they'd be the
best team
in the nfc east right now you take the
cardinals and put them in with the
cowboys giants eagles in washington
cardinals are the best team
nfc west i would say
yeah they are the fourth best team
because the rams the 49ers and the
seahawks are so good and
i with seven playoff teams per
conference there is a chance
every team in the nfc west could get a
playoff berth now that would mean
no team other than the division
champions for the other three
getting in but it could happen stranger
things have happened
uh maybe not that strange as having all
four teams from a division in the
playoffs but it could happen
i think if the cardinals don't make it
to the playoffs this year though the
cardinals are going to move on
from cliff kingsbury the cardinals have
a long history of not sticking with
coaches
for an extended period of time only two
coaches
in the history of the organization have
ever made it six years jim hanafan from
80 to 85
and ken wisenhunt who took the team to
the super bowl
bruce erin's made it five years this is
year three for kingsbury i don't think
he gets a fourth one
if they don't make it to the playoffs
this year you're already picking up on
that vibe
that frustration that irritation from
guys like kyler murray
and and i think this is it for kingsbury
kyme may survive
but i don't think kingsbury does if they
don't make it to the playoffs
this year and it is going to be a
difficult thing
to have happen pfdp and policy as we
continue to see the number of competent
franchise quarterbacks increase
when or will we start to see them
devalued like franchise running back say
you know i i don't think we're going to
see quarterbacks get to the point where
the supply greatly outweighs the demand
that's what we see with running backs
and i think we're going to start to see
that with receivers
because there are so many great
receivers that come out in the draft
every year teams are going to be
reluctant to pay huge money
to their star receiver knowing that they
can just go find another one because so
many guys
every year are making an impact right
away in the nfl
with quarterbacks i think what we're
going to see is
a greater willingness to not give market
value money
to a guy on a second contract and it may
be one of the reasons why baker mayfield
lamar jackson josh allen don't have
their second deals yet
you don't have that same compulsion to
lock
up with the second contract a
quarterback who's landed on the pass
side of pass fail as to whether or not
he's a bust
i think teams now have the luxury to
wait and see whether that player is
going to be a true
short list franchise quarterback because
if he's not
maybe you don't want to break the bank
for him maybe you want to think about
your options and it's one of the reasons
why so many veteran quarterbacks are
available every year
teams want to find a franchise
quarterback they're willing to move on
from a guy who
is good enough but not great enough in
the hopes of finding a guy
who will be the answer for 10 or 15
years or longer and with so many
college quarterbacks coming out now who
are competent and ready to go
coaches willing to embrace the systems
that those quarterbacks
thrived in at the college level that's
what's making teams
less inclined to overpay a guy who is
just
average middle of the pack everyone
wants that franchise guy
who is among the very best in the league
and teams are willing
to let the bird in the hand fly away in
search of the two in the bush because if
all else fails
they'll find another bird in the hand
out there somewhere all right
let's uh let's see what else we got here
probably should wrap this up i'm looking
for a good one looking for a good one
uh let's see here
some some of these are funny i'm not
going to read them out loud i like the
fact that people have
a sense of humor can anyone improve
their accuracy like josh allen did from
year one to year three ever again that's
jp's kubinski
i i don't know that look
i don't know how much of it was josh
allen
suddenly becoming a better quarterback
as it was
the bills surrounding him with the
talent that allowed him
to become a better quarterback you go
out and get staphon diggs you get a high
end receiver all of a sudden
your quarterback looks a lot better you
know one of the knocks on josh allen
coming out of college was his accuracy
was not good well his receivers were not
good
at some level the guy who is
commissioned to run the route
and catch the pass has to do his job or
the quarterback's going to be the one
who bears the brunt
of the incomplete passes so
yes josh allen year three hit a level
that people had assumed based on year
one and two he wasn't going to reach
and and that shows the flaw i think
of coming to
hard and fast conclusions about a guy's
ability based upon one or two years in
the nfl
now now i know that teams are less
patient than they've ever been
with quarterbacks and really players at
any position you used that first round
pick on a guy you wanted to come in and
make an impact right away
but yeah for some guys it takes a little
bit
to get to their ceiling it takes some
help to get to the third
year and have that great season like
allen did so
yeah i could see other quarterbacks
coming in and not having to help around
them the first couple
of years and by year three they have the
help around them and off they go that's
what they expect daniel jones
to do this year for the giants they
expect him to have no excuses with
the first round pick used on cadarius
tony the money that was spent
to bring in kenny gallaudet saquon
barkley back
if and when he's back he recently said
he's not sure when he's going to be
ready to go but
they want daniel jones to have that same
kind of jump this year and if he doesn't
gets back to the prior question from pft
pm posse i think the giants will be
inclined at that point to say hey daniel
we're not giving you a second contract
we'll go find somebody else
maybe we'll keep you for four years
maybe we'll keep you for five years
but after that we're going to move on
and we're not going to make the mistake
of paying you 30 or 35 million just
because we fear
not having someone else who's as good
we'll find someone else
who's as good because there's so many
veterans out there
this is the new normal every free agency
now i believe there will be
more than a handful of quarterbacks with
recognizable names who are available to
be signed
or guys out there who could be traded
for because
teams recognize the younger quarterbacks
coming into the league
better than ever before all right that's
it for today we'll do it again tomorrow
we'll do it every day this week we're
getting ready for the olympics which
launched
this weekend but we're still going to
carve out some time for the pft live pft
pm daily hiatus version of
everything happening in the nfl thanks
as always for some of your time
and we'll talk to you again tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports